ok je vais voler ouais on y va
[Musique]
il faut que tu l'oublies à réagir
comment tu veux toi t'es ingénie
qu'est-ce que j'ai dit
[Musique]
et tu savais ce qu'elle allait arriver à
mon frère quand tu lui as pour gai ton
bidule de destruction massive
on l'appelle le scarabée je m'attendais
pas du tout à ce qu'il s'active il doit
d'abord vous choisir et il faut faire
quoi pour qu'il ne veuille plus de moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis désolé
nous allons changer le monde grâce au
pouvoir du scarabée il n'appartient qu'à
moi
le monde doit être protégé j'ai un
arsenal à disposition fais-toi plaisir
prends-en de la graine Riley
l'amour que tu portes à ta famille
te rend faible tu as tort ma famille
c'est ça qui fait ma force
pardon pour le retard
[Musique]
je vais avoir besoin de ton Arsenal